hi everyone it's your favorite fbi agent
badge number
and today i'll be doing an unboxing
video of box a33 this is one of the
boxes we took from trump's mar-a-lago
home now let's unpack our first item
looks like we have some packaging filler
here you know some basic paper
um actually never mind these are
shredded documents here we have what
seems to be an industrial size bottle of
adderall now most of this seems to be
written in russian
and i don't speak russian so i don't
know what it means but i can say i'm
pretty sure this is illegal to have the
next item are photos of melania trump
with french president emmanuel macron
this comes with a letter from donald
trump to tony ornato dated on
valentine's day oh wow um
this has a lot of swear words in it all
right this is a top secret folder that
has not written on it let's take a look
inside
whoa
wait is that
yep that is definitely ketchup and here
we have a dvd that's titled from russia
with love starring donald j trump and he
seems to be soaked in some sort of
yellow liquid
weird
oh god these are the q-tips make sure to
give this video a like and smash that
subscribe button